in this video we are going to talk about  the three most basic types of values in  JavaScript there's a boolean which is a  true or false statement a string which  is a set of characters inside of either  double quotation or single quotation and  there's numbers for boolean these words  are reserved in JavaScript if you try  and set something equal to true it's  going to that as a boolean value that is  reserved there's a string like hello  hello you can do anything you want  inside of the string as long as it's  inside of the quotes you could say true  or false because it'll be interpreted by  JavaScript as a string third type is  number pretty straightforward its digits  they could have a negative symbol in  front of it or include a decimal point  your three basic types of values are  gonna be boolean strings and numbers